[Music]
hey you guys happy sunday kind of late
today yeah i had a work man over put my
new lights out the work man yeah i had
to get electric
took my
chandelier down which that was good that
[ __ ] was too big room looks big
he was kind of like we came and looked
at the house yeah the the front room it
had like this kind of formal dining room
in it and it had this massive
chandelier it's like a joke i don't
understand it was like
not and it was like and it was low
because it's like a high ceiling but it
was so low that if you walked right
underneath it you would whack your head
yeah and i'm not and i'm like five foot
three and i still was like it was like
that and i was just kind of like that
seems a little impractical put that
there but i mean
i mean i guess normally you would have
like a big table underneath it so people
wouldn't be walking on anything but it
still wasn't big though it was still
like really really big but that thing's
gone our [ __ ] room seems a lot bigger
so the electrician came in he took that
down
and also fixed the lights outside in the
garage i remember if we said this before
but the two outside lanterns like on the
side of the garage whoever was in this
house before
tried to replace the bulbs or never
replaced the bulbs and they exploded no
they all broke or they all broke you
didn't take them out and broke every one
of them there's like three in each they
all broke in the socket yeah and i was
just like these things don't look good
they were ugly anyway
i got rid of so i had a had a white man
come put those up there and i got that
hispanic discount
yeah i got the hispanic discount
yeah because i realized i found out i
was a white hispanic
all right
now i'm just kidding we yeah we talked
about that on friday night well because
because she's amazed now you speak
portuguese
we are barely amazed now that means that
you can it makes sense you gotta you got
irish down in brazil and
you got irish and brazil and and and and
and [ __ ] argentina and paraguay and
uruguay chile is [ __ ] filled with
irish so yeah white hispanic that's
right there's no difference yeah close i
identify yeah
sure that's funny you can identify as
anything and i'm just identifying that
yeah okay that'll work
anyway this was a great movie
uh this movie is called enemy mine
and i saw it when it came out but not in
the theater i saw it on vhs
and i loved it when i saw it but i
always thought of it as like a low
budget movie
if you see it now on a [ __ ] on a good hd
television this [ __ ] looks [ __ ]
great and it's got a great story good
movie
and um called enemy mind
and there is kind of an unofficial
sequel to it
called hunter prey which is hard to find
which didn't we find uh didn't we find
one on youtube that had like
you can watch like arabic subtitles or
something some titles or something you
can watch it for free on maybe we could
we should watch that tonight and talk
about it after this because that movie
is actually not an official sequel but
it's like an unofficial sort of yeah it
talks about it's in the same universe
yeah as it talks about the drax yeah
yeah
it's in the same universe the guys that
made it said that yeah we did we threw
the jacks in there because it's not
copyrighted
yeah they were fans of the show
it's along the same lines i mean
yeah the crazy thing about this movie it
came out in 1985 right
and
i didn't see it in the theater either
i saw it on cable like a year or two
later whenever it came to cable i saw it
when it came out and the weird thing
about it is that i liked it i saw it a
couple of times but when we watched it
again
i found that i had almost like
completely forgotten like the second
part of the film like the third part of
the film after
should we say i mean it's 85 i was gonna
say after spoiler alert after jerry yeah
dies yeah the drag right um i thought i
had remembered that being the end of the
movie no that's because i remember that
happening but i was like no there's like
a whole bunch of movie after that that i
completely and totally forgotten about
yeah jerry died and that's like that
happens in the the last of the that
that's that's the first third of the
movie
yeah i think or at least a half maybe
it's a half movie yeah it was kind of i
think it was like about half maybe
second half of the movie is uh him
raising
jerry's offspring and then trying to and
saving them from the slavers and trying
to return return the child to the drag
and um
the
the
the special effects are fantastic
well it was industrial light and magic
it looks great i did them
yeah i mean they don't they don't i
don't think they look as good as the
ones in star wars
but i mean but the matte paintings and
stuff like that look really good
it says and the makeup looks really good
it's as good as the it's as good as the
um
it's good in terms of special effects i
would say quality on par with like wrath
of khan just that there isn't as many
ship battles in it it's about like that
it's weird because i remember i remember
this being advertised out the [ __ ]
wazoo like in 1985. um and i didn't
realize at the time because i could like
i said i didn't see in the theater i
didn't realize at the time how troubled
this production was and how much of a uh
financial failure it was
um it really only kind of found an
audience later like on cable and vhs
like i guess a lot of these types of
movies did i kind of feel like
they didn't really know how to market it
because they were trying to market it
like a shoot-em-up sci-fi action type of
thing and it's not that
um
friendship yeah there is some of that in
it but i mean the bulk of the movie is
like a drama
mostly it's kind of like of with some
sort of comedic elements toward the
beginning but it's sort of about
you know two enemies like coming to like
finding friendship and survival and like
it's like about brotherhood yeah really
so it's not i kind of feel like they
marketed it more toward like a star wars
type thing yeah and it's not really like
that it's kind of like interstellar race
war these two races are at war with each
other and they both see each other as
the villains
you know i mean like the
the earth people think that they got
attacked and then the drac people think
that we invaded their territory and
they're just fighting it out
uh all kinds of bad [ __ ] happens uh
[ __ ] child's born uh
the drag dies jerry's what what they
called him and then uh he raises the
child tries to get it back to the drag
it's kind of like a robinson caruso
story they're marooned on this planet
um
i think towards the end the war was over
between the drags what did wasn't it i
think it was yeah the war was over with
the drax so it became peace time
which is an important lesson if you have
any military experience whoever you're
fighting a few years later you're now
allies with them that's the constant
theme
and it's the same with this movie is
that the wars don't last long
and uh
so it's kind of like
the story is more about the relationship
between dudes
of of [ __ ] in different planets you
know what i mean throughout war and
peace
but you know spoiler alert
drax only have one sex
they're they're hermaphroditic yeah
they're self-impregnated yeah so they
just kind of get make offspring
so they're they're whatever gender they
have to be at the moment because jerry
does kind of
go a little female once jerry starts
having a child it's weird just got to
see it
good mood
but like i said things change but like i
said they wouldn't have any concept of
that because they don't understand no
there's just one
they're all the same yeah gender there's
no
he was getting motherly though well
that's just because earthlings wrote it
yeah
though it makes sense because that it's
like that it's like that in like mollusk
and mullis life forms and other kind of
life forms that do that too
they almost kind of change gender during
pregnancy for a while then they go back
to being male
it's like they did the sea life yeah you
know
so that's kind of what it does it's both
sex it's whatever sex has to be at the
moment
it's just i kind of feel like i really
like
um
one of the best things about this i
think is
the sort of
i guess it's sort of like dennis quaid's
uh character arc because he kind of
starts out
as kind of a douche yeah i mean he's
just very he hates drax he's you know
he's a fighter pilot he's kind of
cocky hot shot [ __ ] type of dude and
when he first crashed lands on the
planet i mean him and jerry i mean
that's that's not the alien's name but
he has like that's the name he gives him
because it's very glib he can't like
pronounce like his drag name so he just
calls him jerry for short
um but they were have they were doing
like a dog fight right and they just
both like crashed onto this planet and
so for a long time they're just like
distrust and you know they hate each
other
and as the time goes and honestly for a
long time like dennis quaid's character
is kind of just like [ __ ] on us like
making fun of him all the time like
making fun of his this the way he talks
like the way he looks his religion his
religion yeah um you know all this other
kind of [ __ ] so it's nice that and as
the time goes on and i think that's like
kind of the best part of the movie is
just their how their relationship and
friendship develops and this like mutual
respect because he actually does come
down a peg and he actually
asks uh jerry to teach him to speak some
drak um and drac learns english and uh
you know
i guess what's his name what's dennis
quaid's character david uh
he's he calls him like jerry calls him
by his last name
but i can't remember what it was
javin javitch or what magwitch or
something like that i can't remember
what it is
thank you gadgey3
donna is not here but i am tell the wee
hottie she is beautiful anyway if you
don't mind she's the reason i've not
been active love you both
okay donna you're beautiful yeah even
though you're not here you might see
this later though so you are beautiful
donna
um
it was wasn't that a wasn't that a song
donna
by uh [ __ ] man the one that died in the
car the plane crash i can't remember but
yeah so uh i think because i liked that
part of the movie so much and i hadn't
seen it for so long that i thought that
was like the whole movie now
interestingly
this movie is based on a novella
and
the novella
came out in 1979
and that was indeed all of the story it
was just basically them like on the
planet and them you know working
together and you know they were enemies
and blah blah blah the only reason they
added that whole end sequence with like
the miners coming there and uh you know
in enslaving all the drax and uh jerry's
son
uh you know our offspring zamasu zamasu
zami's sammy's
um getting kidnapped and then like you
know david's trying to save him
was because
uh the producers of the film thought
that because it was called enemy mine
that people would be confused if there
wasn't a literal mine
in the movie really yes that's how dumb
isn't that stupid
it's like that's how dumb they think the
people are
also
it's just i don't know they well
obviously they didn't know how to market
this like i said i didn't know i kind of
looked into the background of this this
is actually kind of fascinating they
first started making the movie uh in uh
bulgaria belgium somewhere um and the
first director was richard lon crane who
was the same guy that did brimstone and
treacle and he also did uh full circle
which was what they in britain they
called the haunting of julia which was
based on that peter straub novel i
reviewed it a while back
uh so he was the first guy
but then i guess the budget for this was
only supposed to be i think 17 million
to start with but i guess
um they were shooting in iceland and
they couldn't get the shots they wanted
and the budget kept going up and up and
there were creative differences like
with the director and [ __ ] and so
the studio stepped in and said well we
still want to finish this movie but we
don't want this director on it
so
they brought in
um
wolfgang peterson who was the same guy
that had done he did das boot uh he did
never ending story he did in the line of
fire outbreak air force one perfect
storm he did all those so they brought
him in and when he came in he was kind
of like um
well he's like one all the [ __ ] that
they shot it just looked like earth it
didn't look like another planet so he's
like we're gonna scrap all that and he
wanted to shoot parts of it in africa
and then he shot some of the studio
stuff like in germany
and so he basically started all over
again so this movie ended up costing
like 40 million to make
and i think it only made like less than
10 million back like it came out over
the christmas yeah period in 1985 and
they were expecting it to like do way
better because they spent a [ __ ] ton of
money advertising this they had tv spots
they had posters they had [ __ ]
everywhere and
like i said i kind of feel like and say
even some of the executives said this at
the time they're like we weren't really
sure how to market it because like i
said i think they were trying to market
it as more toward kids as like a yeah
it's like a sci-fi type movie and that's
not really at all what this is
right along the lines of star trek
star yeah
i kind of feel like that would have been
a more because this is a very star trek
type of story you know what i mean
because it's basically i mean it's
basically like
um
you know it's the same thing as
something like district 9 or something
like that which is obviously they're
talking about like racism or you know
things like that and but filtered
through
aliens yeah and humans yeah i mean there
were other movies like this i don't know
why they didn't this this movie that i
remember this movie this this movie
made lewis gossett's is that named
gossett right yeah those guys
gossip that this made his career i mean
he was the first time
this is the first time i ever
knew the existence of that gossip guy
then he went on to do iron eagle and
everything but everyone was talking
about how well he played this alien and
he does
it's not like a person in a suit he
comes off as a real alien
does a great job
yeah i mean and that's another thing
that's another thing too that when they
brought the new director in um he made
them redo
the suit or the makeup because he's like
the first one just looked like a dude in
a rubber suit yeah uh so he actually
wanted to do like a better one and you
knock it off he's pulling she's holding
it down he pulled all
she's like you guys are not paying
attention to me
oh my god you guys you should have heard
her yesterday she did the craziest thing
oh yeah she runs up and down the halls
all the time she's getting zoomies you
know what i mean she's like runs up and
down runs down and yesterday i'm sitting
in here and tom was in the bedroom and i
hear bro
like she runs down the hall and then all
of a sudden i heard rare like this kind
of [ __ ] i can't well i can't do it
because my voice is [ __ ] up it was it
was um
and i leaned out the door i said was
that her yeah i never heard her make
that noise before yeah
he sounded like a little bobcat sounded
like a yeah it sounded like a little
leopard
[Laughter]
like all day we were what the [ __ ] we
both came out like was that like
that's you she's standing there my
doorway the other room the other room
and she's like yeah i'm doing it like
what are you growling for
she was happy i know she looked all like
tough and everything yeah i never heard
her make that noise all day yesterday we
were trying to get her to do it again
but she wanted it
she had to be in the mood i guess she
was like fantasizing about like being on
the serengeti or something like that
chase you got a hell girl yeah guess i
don't know i just couldn't believe that
was her but louis goss this this movie
here made his career
uh if you ask me it did
this under his belt and all of a sudden
you started seeing him a lot in the 80s
and the 90s
and
he was in a lot of action movies and
stuff he never played a role quite this
good
so he didn't give him the material i
guess yeah i kind of feel like this was
probably his best role yeah to be honest
with you yeah he shows his skill quite
well in this it's worth it just to see
his portrayal of the alien i heard that
he's still that he'll still do the drac
voice like at conventions and stuff if
they ask him to yeah like so i guess he
enjoyed doing the role yeah i mean that
suit looks great it still looks great
from like the movie looks real it's a
high budget movie it's it's as good as
say like wrath of khan it's just that
it's not ship combat it's on this it's
on a planet yeah there is some ship
combat it's just not not very long it's
not real impressive you know what i mean
in terms of you know like rather con or
something but in terms of quality it's
it's it's as good as that and i was
going man this movie looks [ __ ] great
um you know there's some alien creatures
that they got to deal with and damn
thing like a damn sarlacc [ __ ] comes
out of the ground and grabs people
they're trying to survive
yeah i was like oh look it's like it's
like yeah
and then um
there's an angle of the story added in
there
during this war because the tracks
weren't human
they uh kind of had a law where you kind
of could enslave a drag
and uh they had these looking scavengers
these [ __ ] scum bags
who were uh
captured uh buying captured or uh drax
and working them to death in these mines
and
zombies gets [ __ ] captured by them
because they they stop by the planet
and uh the dennis quaid character go
tries to hunt down which is actually a
good part of the movie tries to hunt
these scavengers down see where they are
and save zamies from the scavengers
because that's essentially his son i
mean he's raising him from his baby
right they grow fast for though it was
only a few years yeah
and uh
so he goes in there and leaves and
leaves a slave revolt against the uh
the um
the uh
the miners because he can speak drastic
so he goes in there and like right and
they know who he is because zombies says
he told him that he would come to get
him you know eventually he called him
uncle yeah caught him uncle and uh
but then uh soon after the war was over
so they were they had to stop all that
and uh it ends with the scene where he
takes uh zambia's back to the drag home
world and he's got to recite this big
thing in a in a big ceremony to get him
you know to like join the the uh drac
society you know and like uh humans and
drax are allies now at this point which
that's talked about later
in kind of like the spiritual sequel of
this which is uh um hunter hunter prey
which maybe we should watch tonight so
we can watch tonight
i wish you know the quality isn't real
high you can watch for free on youtube
but it's a [ __ ] to get i looked it up
and there was like no there's no
streaming services thank you again
gadgey3 did you get the garage lights
done yes we did yeah yeah yes we got the
garage lights done and we got the big
ugly
chandelier taken down from the dining
room yeah that we didn't like
[Laughter]
yeah so uh i really recommend hunter
prey the the copy on youtube is not that
good and it looks like it has like a
hindi or some kind of hindi or sanskrit
subtitles underneath it i haven't been
able to watch it all it looks complete i
kind of skimmed through it real quick it
looked like it was all there
um the
it's kind of low resolution the graphics
are kind of inferior
but
if you like it you can buy it then you
can get it on dvd but it it's pretty
expensive it's 20 bucks on dvd yeah it's
really one of those movies for some
reason it's just like really difficult
to get hold of which is a shame because
it's really good it's real good and
amazon lists uh a blu-ray for 40.
i don't know who who's got it but um
hunter prey isn't small indie film but
it's done really well real well it's as
good as this
if not maybe a little bit better
i kind of like the story out of 100 prey
a little bit better but they're both
good they're both good i had actually
forgotten like i said i hadn't seen this
movie in so long um i didn't know that
it was the same director that did never
ending story but that totally makes
sense because this is
th the tone of this kind of reminds me
of never ending story a little bit a
little darker uh yeah i guess so but it
is kind of like similar some people have
said the alien and this looks like the
one from the last starfighter which yeah
i kind of feel like i was watching uh
red letter media did uh did a thing of
this just a couple weeks ago
and he was uh saying that he confused
this movie with the last starfighter
sometimes i guess just because the alien
kind of looks a lot better than last
star yeah i remember this last
starfighter was okay but i remember
liking this one a lot better honestly
more authentic yeah i mean i really
liked like uh you know the just the
whole heartfelt relationship between
dennis quaid and i honestly for 1985
because i think i was saying this to you
while while we were watching it because
i remembered uh jerry you know the the
alien like getting pregnant and having a
baby it's like i remembered all that
but i had forgotten like how for 1985 i
was like wow that's it's really kind of
like ahead of its time i mean he kind of
like dennis quaid was like laughed and
thought it was like funny that you know
the the what he thought was a male alien
was pregnant but they didn't really make
a huge deal about it and i was like
watching this other review too this
might have been the red letter media too
but they said i really they said they
really liked the way because they said
you know how sometimes like in movies
particularly from the 80s
um you know you'd have two guys who were
like friends who were hanging out and
they always had to be like i am super
straight you know what i mean i was
banging all these chicks and everything
so if there'd be like a no homo kind of
moment um you know so you wouldn't think
that there was any gay stuff going on
like between the two male characters um
they didn't do that in this one and i
thought it was like way better for it
and i thought and i liked the way dennis
quaid's character was just kind of like
he thought it was funny like because he
thought it was weird but then he was
like okay and then like as soon as he
saw the baby he was like okay i'm taking
care of this baby now and it was just
like and he just raised the kid and i
just thought that was pretty awesome
well he didn't think about it he said he
had heard that tracks only had one
gentleman yeah
but he didn't think about it
yeah but then when he actually saw it i
guess it sort of made him a little bit
uncomfortable but then he just kind of
like rolled with it and i thought that
was kind of cool i'm like wow that's
like really ahead of its time for 1985.
it was well it's the same in the same
spirit of star trek yeah it's handled
the same way star trek would have
handled it yeah you know so that's yeah
that's actually a good that's probably
who they should have they should have
marketed this more toward star trek
older trekkies yeah um
rather than toward you know sort of
teenage boys that would have gone to see
like an action-packed more star wars-y
type of movie i'd have tagged it on the
[ __ ] star trek
yeah i think that would have done a lot
better i mean this is just one of those
ones that
man it just it really tanked and
i mean it's just bad luck bad luck it
was um and like i said they didn't
really know how to market it they
marketed the [ __ ] out of it they did
spend a lot of money marketing but they
didn't know
they didn't really know what demographic
to target it toward it it seemed like
i'd be curious to see what that did on
vhs because i remember renting it all
the time well that's when i know that's
when it picked up yeah that's when it
picked up i'm talking about like it's
theatrical right uh it really nobody
went to see it it just made like way
less money than they were expected like
way less money than they were expecting
and um you know and
added that to the fact that it cost much
more than they were expecting to make
because they had to switch out the
directors and all this other kind of
[ __ ] and they had to move the you know
they had to redo the makeup and they had
to move the location and all this other
stuff and actually the actors like
dennis quaid and louis gossett jr they
actually had to sit out so they had to
pay them while while they were sitting
out while they were sorting out you know
all the new [ __ ] they had to do and they
had to throw out all of the i think that
nine million dollars worth of
footage they had already done that they
weren't going to use so that just like
went down the toilet
so you know i so i just kind of feel
like it you know then they didn't know
how to market it they were trying to
make their money back they didn't really
know what they were doing and
but it was one of those ones that found
its audience later on because that's
kind of like
in the video store you know it's cheap
and you could just kind of walk around
and it was like three or four bucks and
you know so it wasn't really as big a
deal like if you rented something you
didn't like it yeah so what
um but it was also kind of a thing too
if you really liked it then you'd go
back and rent it again yeah uh because
it wasn't expensive so
you know just
i didn't rent it but i saw it on cable
it was on cable a lot and i do kind of
feel like it's one of those movies that
a lot of people saw back in the 80s and
remember really fondly yeah um just
coming across that on cable but you
wouldn't necessarily have gone to see it
in the theater
yeah you know what i mean which which
would have been like uh this which would
have kind of sucked because
seeing this on vhs
it didn't translate well to [ __ ] vhs
and to crt television it just didn't
look that good
see it on [ __ ] hd and it's like man
this move this looks [ __ ] great we
were watching i was like i had no idea
this movie looked so good yeah so i
thought this was a low budget movie no
it's a [ __ ] expensive movie but like
i said industrial light at magic
did the effects really good some of i
think some of the green screen stuff
isn't great but a lot of the stuff from
85 isn't uh the makeup looks really good
and like i said the stuff with the matte
paintings and some of the miniatures and
stuff like that look really really good
for 85 this is fantastic oh yeah you
know i'm sorry i think it's fine
fantastic for 85. that's as good as
rathacon
and but the thing is is that the the
special effects are more oriented
towards uh backdrops and
uh planetscapes of the planet that
they're on um
the creatures that they have to deal
with and just like uh the environment
that they're in
uh stuff that happens in the mine also
looks real good
but most of it's kind of
nature on an alien world and you buy it
i bought it i didn't in vhs but you see
it on [ __ ] hd television and [ __ ]
man it looks really good
real artistic that's kind of one
that's one nice thing about nowadays is
that all of these movies from the 80s
that
you know even if you appreciated them
back then like you couldn't unless you
saw them in the theater you saw them on
vhs or you know on your crappy like
cable and it looked like ass and so it's
so nice now that all of these companies
are actually like releasing them and
fixing them all up so they look like
what they were intended
to look like like what you would have
seen if you saw in the theater or maybe
even better right so i think that's
really cool so you're actually seeing
them in their you know pristine like
their best presentation possible yeah
and to compare that drac to the alien
from last starfighter no not even close
if you actually put them side by side
the one from the last star fighter that
guy was just acting like a dude in a
costume and they it they actually it
didn't look very real this looks real
you know i say in terms of like of
convincing you that yeah that might be
an alien creature i put up there with
the predator from predator one it looked
like a creature
you know the thing for predator one was
a lot of [ __ ] scarier
but the i'm saying the makeup effects
were as convincing as predator one just
a different creature yeah it looked like
a real alien like a humanoid reptilian
alien yeah it didn't look like a dude in
a costume and the way he's moving and
talking you know it looks like an a you
know he's putting a lot of work into it
it's it's a convincing character yeah i
mean he went all in yeah uh and like i
said the voice was great like the body
movements were great his eyes and his
eyes
yeah i think the eyes looked where the
eyes were really good those are some
good yeah and he's got his own culture
and everything and he tries to have a
sense of humor and he's not really good
at it but he gets a little better you
know it's just you just got to see the
movie it's good denis didn't he tell
dennis quaid at one point that uh mickey
mouse was a big stupid dope yeah
[Laughter]
he had tricked him and told that mickey
mouse was the teacher of great wisdom
he'd always come back but mickey mouse
was a big dude
he's trying to be [ __ ] slick and [ __ ]
so what did we watch this on this was on
it was like uh amazon prime watch it on
no did we did we paid right it was three
yeah i think it was free wouldn't it
maybe we didn't pay it was either free
or is 3.99 i can't remember but um
no i think it was free doesn't didn't it
offer it for free maybe i can't get it
but yeah if you have amazon prime you
probably get it so yeah if you haven't
seen it since the 80s totally because i
have probably hadn't seen it since the
late 80s much nicer than you thought it
was and yeah and i had totally forgotten
like i said i totally forgot the whole
part at the end like with the kid
getting kidnapped and enslaved and
everything i i thought the end of it was
like when when the dra when uh jerry
died
and uh so because i was like oh bummer
and i told him i said maybe the reason i
thought that was because i was so bummed
out by it that i just like just blacked
out the rest of the movie because i was
like sad but
so i had forgotten that so it was kind
of like cool to see it again you know
i still think that the first part of the
movie with the with the two of them
interacting is the best part
um but it does get more action-packed
toward the end plus brian james is in it
he's like uh
a villain so he's always good to see he
always i feel like he always plays a
villain that [ __ ] wasn't blade runner
he was in everything oscar's talking
about zardoz
you gotta see zardoz man you gotta see
zardos
zardoz is a good one
we tell we talked about zardo not too
long ago i think we did a matinee but if
you like this i just want to remind you
go ahead and see uh hunter pray
there's a an inferior copy i'm going to
call it an inferior guy there's an
inferior copy on for free on youtube
with subtitles on it um
if you like it
it's even better to see it on on dvd i
saw it on dvd it looked great this is
before blu-ray yeah we might watch it
tonight yeah we might watch it we'll
probably watch it tonight yeah and then
we can talk about it tomorrow because
it'll be good because then
um you know because i think when we
watched it before
and you were like oh it's you know it's
a spiritual sequel whatever to enemy
mind but i hadn't seen enemy mind for
such a long time that i didn't remember
but now that we've seen enemy mine
recently then it'll be like a lot more a
little more action than enemy mine yeah
but it's it's good real
[ __ ] excellent [ __ ] uh costumes
and special effects it's kind of like
these kind of like stormtrooper type
imperial soldiers
hunting down this fugitive alien that
escaped capture it's like super
dangerous and they gotta [ __ ] find it
and they're on this desert planet not in
the mojave desert really but they
[ __ ] the way they shot it you do
believe you're in an alien desert
and uh the fun goes from air
kind of like i don't know and then
there's
reveals and [ __ ] as it goes along pretty
good movie real good
all right so
uh you want to wrap it up for the
evening because i'm kind of sleepy i
don't know why i got plenty of sleep but
oh and i forgot to tell you guys it's
you know it's florida but
last night it went down to
26 degrees yeah fahrenheit there was a
hard freeze warning yep
uh my mom in ocala actually like wrote
to me and she was like they said it's
gonna snow
and she was like cut and she was like
cutting wood for the fireplace and also
in case their power went out so it was
like freaking out so it does actually
get cold here sometimes i think it's
supposed to be like hard freeze tonight
too but i think it's gonna start warming
back up again tomorrow but yeah so it
was super cold last night so it does get
like that sometimes all right so
that'll do it uh for this
show
so have a good rest of your sunday
evening and we'll be back tomorrow
talking about another movie all right
thanks everybody for dropping by and
thanks for super chats and we'll see you
tomorrow
bye